okay
as well
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
wow
good evening
hi welcome to the table
i'm glad that you're here my name is don
jacobs i'm one of the part of the
leadership here that's here at the table
i'm glad that you all could make it here
this evening
um so before we get started to do a
couple of announcements um we are doing
our state of the table
uh meeting next sunday uh so that's a
right after the service is just a great
time to just kind of know we're kind of
where we are
um just kind of figure out maybe places
you could possibly get plugged in um if
you're not already uh also places where
you can we get to be somewhat
transparent with you guys so you guys
just kind of know
all the ins and outs of the things that
kind of happen behind the scenes that
you see more than just
this service so it's a great time for
you to cut more information about what
we're doing
um another quicker reminder announcement
i know we've been talking about this
often we're going to continue talking
about this but we have a centerpiece
conference that's happening
at the first week in november
that's just another great way to kind of
get more somewhat educated a little bit
on our conversations surrounding lgbtq
issues specifically in faith spaces um
so that's a great place if you are
a member of lgbtq awesome we'd love to
have you there if you're an ally again
awesome we would love to have you there
as well
but it's going to be a great place for
people to be educated and find support
so again it's the first weekend it's
like a thursday friday and saturday
of the first week in november
the other thing is is that today
is um september um 11th
and so that's just kind of an
interesting
memory because it's about 21 years
since that actually happened
and it's really weird to kind of
actually say that out loud because my
kids are not even 20 something years old
and so it's kind of a for those of us
who remember that
kind of a jarring
memory
i'm sure most of us can remember exactly
where we were exactly what we were doing
when all of that happened and so it just
can bring up
some interesting feelings and emotions
and just everything goes along with it
we do have a lot of first responders
part of our community
um we want to think about them because
they are the first people to respond to
situations like that they are the first
people to put their feet on the ground
in those situations
um
it's also one of those times where you
can look back on it and get really
frustrated with certain things
i remember how sometimes our muslim
americans were treated during that time
very similarly recently however a lot of
our asian americans were treated during
covet very similar types of situations
but my favorite thing i will say this is
kind of weird what i remember about 911
it brought us together as americans for
some reason i felt proud to be american
for whatever reason and it just kind of
united us
and especially in a time where we can be
very divided and very tribal especially
right now
um
it's kind of important to remember that
that's the thing that can unite us and
we are together in all of our different
things we have a common common thing
so
um so with that being said we are here
for a common reason here too in this
space and in this church and here in our
faith community
and so i hope that you opened your
hearts and your minds to the worship
time that's about to happen
to the words are going to be shared
during the service to communion
and just think about the things that are
bringing us together while we are here
so with that being said
let me open you up with prayer
lord thank you so much for this time
this day this space to be able to come
here
to connect with other people
and just remember who you are
and what you mean to us and who you say
you are because we know that we are
loved
and blessed by you
and i pray you open our hearts and minds
to what you have for us this evening in
christ's name i pray amen
amen
thank you don
um we are so excited for y'all to be
here if you want to stand with us we're
going to take the next little while here
to worship together and if that's a new
setting for you i just want to
dismantle any kind of nervousness or
awkwardness that you might be feeling um
this is a space where your story and
whatever you walk into this room with is
welcome
and even wanted here so um
sing along if you'd like to sing along
if taking in the lyrics and just kind of
using it as almost like a meditation
it's something that would speak to your
heart i just want you to receive
whatever god might have for you in this
moment and however that looks is great
so
dance clap sit stand
but you're welcome here
[Music]
healed they're broken back together
the poor are blessed
we will dance forever
[Applause]
the blinded sea
the chained are free
the
now
believer
the outcast known
the orphan home
you are my redeemer
behold
[Music]
he's making all things new
the lost return the voiceless heard
the mourner now rejoicing
the mountain shape the world awake
creational composing
the sad and true the earth we
[Music]
the knew
he's making all things
[Music]
enjoy
tears
[Music]
again
we
[Music]
will love him
is
[Music]
me
all right
you kiddos are dismissed to your classes
and we're going to keep going with our
set
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
with grace
i am
[Music]
is
you cover me with
[Music]
is
i am
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
i am
[Applause]
[Music]
is
me
[Music]
thank you god for our freedom
thank you for what you set us free from
god
we're gonna move into the prayers of the
people
and joe's gonna read that aloud for us
and if you guys would just join us and
read aloud with her the words will be on
the screen and if you're online you're
welcome to leave a comment in that
section when we
are offering up our own requests
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and sick for the widow and
orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them we pray
to you
[Music]
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
the andreas
uh
[Music]
for our teachers
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud
and for those that we have kept in our
hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and in a deep sense of your
presence
amen
pain
i wonder if i'll ever
find my way
i wonder if my life could really
changed
[Music]
could a garden come up
is
[Music]
peace
is
[Music]
you'll make beautiful things
is
[Music]
beautiful things
you make beautiful things
[Music]
you make
are me
me do
you
make
[Music]
me
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
you
are me
[Music]
you
make me
tonight as we sing those words out loud
together we remember
that the story is not over with you
that our darkest moments
and the times that we are grieving are
overcome overwhelmed
stressed broken hurt
divorced addicted
depressed
anxious
even in those moments you are there
and you have the ability to recreate and
renew and restore and redeem us
you are our hope
you are our anchor
and you've made room for each one of us
you have invited us into your family
you give us a seat at the table
you know us
and you see us and you formed us and you
said it was good
help us to remember that help us to live
as people who are loved
who are found worthy
[Music]
god and would we make space for others
would we invite them in
and would we watch you do your good work
in each one of our stories god
do your thing
come and do your work in us
recreate us
[Music]
make us new
thank you for who you are thank you for
the way that you love us
accept us forgive us
and make us new
it's in your name we ask each one of
these things and thank you for this time
together
amen
before you guys sit down could you turn
to the people around you and just
welcome them make them feel at home and
then we'll sit down and brett will get
us started on the message
good evening
grace and peace
uh it is so good to be with you all um
so
and as always i don't want to forget
those joining us online
thank you for being with us and um and
everyone here who is uh new maybe it's
your first or second third time you're
kind of you know
feeling it out i'm really really glad to
have you with us we really we long to be
a just a hospitable um welcoming people
because that's who that's who christ was
so
i hope you can sense that tonight
so uh we are if you are here for the
first time this is a great night because
um we are beginning a new series uh
titled unclean drawing near in a runaway
world
and um if if you've been around the
table you know we do we tend to do
different types of series sometimes
we'll join the church calendar and do
like lent or advent
other times we'll go through a book of
the bible and we'll do like a topical
series and so this is actually different
than anything i've ever done
but this is a series based actually on a
book written by the christian
psychologist richard beck
and he's out of abilene christian
university and um
and i've never done this i think
generally just because our tradition
just the way we've done it is you know
it's always focused on specifically like
a scripture or um something along those
lines so this is a little bit different
in that what we're going to do is kind
of i'll engage his book i'm not trying
to like
give you every concept or idea from it
obviously um but i'm going to kind of
use some insight or section of it um and
then what i want to do is try to give us
a new angle on
scripture often it will be from the
gospels
matthew mark luke john so that's kind of
where we're going in this series and
it's yeah i think it should be a really
really meaningful
time
as we go through this over the next i
think it'll be about five weeks so um
with that in mind
the title of the message tonight is the
danger of disgust the danger of disgust
so um the heart of the the book unclean
revolves around something called disgust
psychology
um
which you know in many ways it's
probably maybe this is like a likely a
new term for you this isn't something we
go around talking a lot about um but
honestly it's one of those things that's
sort of invisible to us and yet it it
kind of pervades our world it colors our
own lives it colors um
our relationships the ways we interact
with people so although at least um
through the first few minutes of this
message you may be like
i don't get it what on earth does this
have to do with christian faith um my
hope is
that eventually you'll start to see the
connection um
now before we jump in i do want to name
that this the first kind of seven eight
minutes this message are a little bit
gross um partly because discussed
psychology has to do with things we find
disgusting yes you know a track and
yeller on it tonight um so because that
you know a lot of the examples and
things are just kind of gross don't
worry i won't like show any pictures or
anything so hopefully just my words i
don't know if some of you have a strong
gag reflex
you know you're just oh
um
sorry but i will i will make it quick um
so so all right so what is discussed
psychology so in short it's basically
anything that gives us that human oh so
human reaction of uh
um and there's a lot of things that do
this so it could be like for example
foods um this is often largely
culturally determined right like in one
culture snails are like ooh
and then another culture is like oh i
would never eat a snail you know um
or
um sometimes it's like textures of a
food you know smells
or for almost anyone you know the site
of like mold growing on your grapes in
the fridge you know it's just like oh no
um it's just it's it's a gross thing
right so it's food um it can be body
products um i'm thinking i won't go into
all of them but you know
sweat um things like a vomit right would
be another one i know um
i have a few preteen boys in my house um
one nephew and then two of my boys and
they don't realize it but they are
firmly in the place of needing deodorant
badly but they insist they're like no
i'm fine i'm like dude i can smell you
from here and like go ahead smell and
there's like they're like oh i'm like
yeah you need this but then they just
insist like here's some old spice buddy
and they're like actually oak my
youngest yesterday was before soccer
games and i was like yeah we need we
need this and he's like no no he's like
i hate it just such a strong
smell that old spice he's like i hate it
he's like you know what i want dad i
want a deodorant that smells like sweat
and i was like bro you do not get it
um
so it can be body products it can be
animals
uh some of you insects that are kind of
like you know or uh like june bugs this
seems to be a thing i'm not i'm fine
with the june bugs something about those
prickly legs
[Laughter]
or anyone um rats
yeah that would be my wife uh if there's
just knowledge if we told her maggie
there's a rat in that room just that
knowledge just the idea of it in you
know just enough to make her skin crawl
um or it could be of course um dead
things um violations to the the form of
the body the especially the outer form
so if you've ever like been watching
sports maybe and you see an injury and
it's like the elbow's not supposed to go
that way oh gosh oh gosh it's so it's a
weird thing you're like i need to watch
i can't watch
oh my god you know um
so this is all discussed psychology
happening in us now okay so what is this
about um what is what is going on here
well uh psychologists have identified a
few purposes to this so um
first it's about boundaries
so in other words
you've got to kind of monitor what is
within you and what is you and then what
is not you and often it's things that
are not us that we kind of find um
disgusting so like for example um
saliva is this way this is sort of weird
that i'm assuming most of you like
swallow all day but if i said hey i've
got this perfectly clean cup
go ahead and spit in it
and then sorry i told you it's gonna be
a little gross uh you know
drink it back
most of you would have a hard time with
that right even though
just five seconds ago you're about to do
this exact same thing you're about to
swallow
why oh it's the difference it's like
well
see there's a thing there's a difference
between saliva it is me
but the minute it leaves me now it's not
that is spit oh that's that is
disgusting no i don't want anything to
do with that oh yeah but i'll swallow
you know it's a weird right so it's
about it's about boundaries what does it
mean what does not me um it's also about
um what is like expelling
so if there's something kind of foreign
or a pollutant or contamination or
something in you and it's like i gotta
get this out um
you know i'm thinking like of course
vomit is this or
um i'm thinking of the weird fascination
people have with cleanses
where they get really you don't have to
raise your hands some of you are really
into the cleanses you know i remember
like 10 years ago there was this one
going around of like
lemon juice
cayenne pepper
and maybe apple cider vinegar or
something and people were like five days
nothing but this you know and it's like
it's awesome for my liver i know i have
no idea the scientific backing i've
heard of a lot of these cleanses a
little questionable whether you know i
don't know if you've done double blind
placebo tests on the the cayenne pepper
cleanse but what is it about right we
love this idea of like oh i'm just i'm
just getting it out all those toxins i
could just i can almost feel it just
leaving my body you know um what is that
that's that's discussed psychology and
we're just like yes i'm getting i'm
getting clean here you know um another
thing and maybe most of all um beyond
just boundaries or getting rid of what
is foreign um this is about
contamination
um this is why like if you go for
example to
a restaurant and you get like your
favorite soup and then you get that big
spoon
and you lift it up you all know where
i'm going and trailing from the soup
is a hair right and you're just like oh
and here's what's interesting if the
waiter waitress comes by and you're like
oh and they're like oh my gosh i'm so
sorry and they grab it and they remove
it
right that hair it you don't say like oh
thank you so much okay
right no what do you say
take that i need a new bowl of soup why
they just got the contaminant right out
what are you worried about it's gone
well
it's just it's it's this idea right it's
contaminated
um and we'll get in in a second into
some of the properties of this um
and
another another good example there was
um dr beck talks about a study by dr
paul derosen where he had test test
subjects and he um poured a glass of
juice and then got a dead cockroach
and he swirled it around in the juice
and then removed the cockroach and then
offer the juice to people
and predictably
pretty much everyone was like nope
nope nope nope
not having that now here's what's
interesting though he then took the
juice
and ran it through a machine and
sanitized it purified it to the point
literally that like filtered it to the
point it was tap water like it wasn't
even juice anymore because it filtered
out all the juice it's just clean pure
water scientifically proven
and uh then he offered that glass of
water
they're like here you go
will you drink it
still
no
why because that darn water that had a
cockroach in it and if once contaminated
always condemn it like it's it's this
idea right it's just like
and you can see here that this is
largely about um
like this isn't just rational or logical
some of these things you think well of
course that's that's gross or i don't
know if something animal or something
could get you sick but you can see that
it starts this shades beyond just what
is logical or makes sense this is like
there's something
deep within us
operating at the level of disgust
psychology um
to kind of unpack contamination for he
gives four principles of contamination
some of these are pretty um
uh
makes it's just practical sense right
kind of intuitive but some are not so um
and hang with me i'm going somewhere
don't you worry this isn't just a
lecture on discuss psychology
um so number one is uh first principle
contamination is contact right of course
you have to be either touch it or in
proximity to the pollutant um so contact
it's about dose it's very dose
insensitive
meaning it doesn't have to be a lot
right just a little bit is enough to
they've even
pointed out like if they do a study like
in a in a school park or something like
a playground and find like traces of a
pollutant that couldn't hurt the kids
like at all it's just so small
doesn't matter people freak
like no it's right and this is disgust
psychology hitting it's like danger
danger danger danger right doesn't
matter if it's smaller can't even hurt
you doesn't matter psychologically no
want nothing to do with it um so contact
dose insensitive permanence right this
is back to the cockroach once
contaminated
always contaminated and then finally
negativity dominance in other words it's
it's always the pollutant that defiles
um never the reverse this is why like if
you drop your napkin on the floor at the
restaurant you don't say like oh good
that floor looked dirty i'm glad my
napkin could like clean it up a little
bit
um no what do you say like oh girl my
napkin is now
gross right it's disgusting because it's
always the negative the pollutant which
is dominant in our minds um
now
left at the level of rotten foods and
you know all these things i think
discuss psychology would be
certainly not worth a uh
not a series maybe not even worth a
sermon um
but what's kind of interesting is um
discuss psychology does not stop there
it does not stop at
things
i want to read this is from matthew
chapter 9 verses 9 through 12.
as jesus went on from there
he saw a man named matthew sitting at
the tax collector's booth
follow me he told him
and matthew got up and followed him
while jesus was having dinner at
matthew's house
many tax collectors and sinners came and
ate with him and his disciples
when the pharisees saw this
they asked his disciples
why
why does your teacher eat with tax
collectors and sinners
on hearing this jesus said it is not the
healthy who need a doctor
but
the sick
if i had to sum up this entire message
in just a few statements
it would be this the danger of disgust
psychology
is the way that it invades our moral
imaginations
it is not merely things
that we come to view as unclean
it
is
people
it is people
you see what's interesting about this
story from matthew 9
is
that nearly everything we just spent 10
minutes talking about on disgust and
contamination
it's almost all there
like it's all there in the story first
you have jesus right the the holy kind
of
person
right the the pure one
and then what does he do he invites who
the unclean he invites matthew the tax
collector he says follow me
but then he doesn't stop there where
does he go
to his house he goes into his house and
then it gets even worse at least from
the perspective of the pharisees because
who's there in matthew's house
his friends
right other unclean people and then it
gets even worse
what does he do once he's there
he starts taking food food that they
might have touched
and he's putting it in his mouth he's
eating with them now by my count that is
three of the four marks of contamination
you have contact right he's in the house
rubbing shoulders with them maybe even
embracing them
uh you've got permanence this idea that
jesus is now permanently making himself
unclean
um and then finally you've got
negativity dominance
right there's notice there's no thought
by the pharisees that oh good
jesus is going right where he ought to
go you know like he is he is rendering
those folks clean
that is not the logic is it
why because it's the negative that is
dominant
and and so the idea is jesus is now
rendering himself unclean
by
engaging with them you see the danger of
disgust is the way it invades our moral
imaginations it is not merely things
that we come to view as unclean it is
people um now you might ask the question
though why
like how do we go from i don't like mold
on food
two
people are disgusting
can you see like that seems like quite
the
quite the logical leap
um
how do we do it uh beck he points out
that it seems to be about moral
metaphors
if you notice pretty much all of the
ways we talk about sin and wrong doing
and
and your morals and ethics and such is
almost always in metaphorical language i
grew up in a tradition where we had like
sunday evening
testimony night
where people would share like stories of
like what god's doing in their life or
transformation even here at the table
we've had set aside sundays where people
share their stories and um
if you pay attention to the the language
of people you'll notice they're almost
always using metaphors maybe you've
heard
language like this
there was a season in my life where i
was just on the wrong path
i was just far from god
but christ in his grace
he found me
right can you hear the metaphor there
it's lost and found right or maybe um
you've heard someone say there was a
season in my life where
my soul i was like i was just sick on
the inside my soul was sick
i was um
struggling with depression i
felt addicted i was oh i was a mess my
soul was sick but
christ in his grace
healed and restored me
and you can see right this is the way we
speak
but what's what's another metaphor and
actually some of the most common
metaphors that we use
it's the language of unclean
we say those people or maybe we don't
say it
maybe we just think it
those people are unclean
impure
unacceptable
and
you you can see
that this is this is what happens
the way beck puts it is he says
all sin
might be equal
but all metaphors
are not
and um
i think the dangerous part of a purity
metaphor
is the way it it pairs up and kind of
triggers in us discussed psychology
right and this is why looking at someone
and saying
um you know you're you're disgusting
or you're dirty i mean i think of even
like um the way this plays out on like
the playground among kids you know with
the cootie talk and the ew and the you
know it's almost like little
they're learning that disgust psychology
you know the problem is they grow up
right and it gets nastier and you can
see where that becomes it becomes such a
powerful um
moral metaphor for your if you do that
if you go that road you go down the path
like that is your you're rendered
unclean you can see that that doesn't
have the like um or that's that's such a
powerful punch that's so different than
being like you're on the wrong path
you know i mean like that doesn't have
quite the same
emphasis you know i mean of
you are dirty
and and why because of discussed
psychology and because of you can see
the the fear of contamination right if
someone's on the wrong path well that's
them
but when someone's dirty
what's how does that hook up with
discuss psychology what do we suddenly
fear might i get kind of pulled into
their orbit might it's it's the
pharisees all over again it's the same
thing playing out
and what's the emotion that flows from a
purity metaphor
it's it's shame
purity moral metaphors stir up shame in
us like nothing else
one of the um
iconic images
of the last 10 years or so is the one of
pope francis
maybe you've seen this where he is
embracing
he's kissing the forehead of
and praying over and blessing
a man with
something called neurofibromatosis
have you has anyone seen these images
it's incredibly powerful so
this is this man has a condition where
basically the the nerve endings sprout
tumors
and um can ooze and there they can be
painful
and um
so after this this image um was taken
some journalist
actually tracked down the man they found
him
and uh his name is venicio riva
and he was interviewed
after this
moment
and
what he said was that he has lived his
whole life
of people being afraid of him
and
reacting to him with disgust in fact he
even told a story to the journalist that
one day he um he boarded
a bus
and
a person or two on the bus literally ran
him off the bus
um and so he went to uh pope francis
when he was speaking you know there's
something thousands of people there
and the pope singled him out and this is
we have the quote that benicio shared he
said he the pope pope francis he didn't
have any fear of my illness
he embraced me without speaking
i quivered
i felt a great
warmth
when i think of who christ was
i think of this picture
because the truth is i think for all of
us
um
i'll say many of us tonight i want to
give you both an encouraging word and a
challenge
the encouraging word
is that
um
some of you
have been living in shame
because people may be a pastor
maybe church folks maybe someone just in
authority or just the culture you just
picked up on this idea that you are
somehow unclean in the eyes of god
and and i just want to name that that is
a lie
you are not
unclean
you are a child of the living god made
in his image
beautiful
acceptable
worthy of love
this is who you are
now that's the encouraging word the
challenge
is that at some level
all of us
because of discussed psychology
um all of us
have without knowing it
um
day in day and day out have been tempted
to begin to live like the pharisees
driven by purity metaphors and discuss
psychology
we have been tempted to think of others
as unclean
but god is calling us to more
god is calling us
like christ
like in that moment pope francis
to
pronounce god's welcome
his grace
his love his acceptance of
everyone
and so that's what this series is going
to be about
and um
i hope you'll be able to journey journey
along with us
so as we come to the table of the lord
tonight
as we um take in
the body of christ in the bread
as we take in the blood of christ in the
wine
may it may it be a moment where you i
just want you to have a moment with god
you know maybe tonight you're in the
place of um needing that encouraging
word
maybe you just need a moment to let that
sink in
or maybe you're in a place tonight where
you realize oh my goodness
i've not only been living in shame i've
like been projecting that shame onto
others
in ways i didn't even realize
and maybe you need a moment with god to
um ask his forgiveness
to say lord i i want to love like you
love
um so whatever you need tonight as you
come forward i i hope you can um receive
it
so here at the table we practice what's
called an open table meaning if you're
here tonight and you want to participate
then you are welcome to do that
regardless of you know denominational
affiliation or whatever um you are
you're welcome here
so uh this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord jesus who invites
you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him
should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
as joshua leads us in this last song
you're welcome to stand and sing with us
if you would like to or just sit back
and take it in um
the the main
takeaway from this song is this phrase
that keeps repeating be kind to yourself
be kind to yourself
be kind to yourself and
when brett was wrapping up his message
it just made me think about probably how
this message is hitting all of us
differently and for me i think
god does the most work in my heart when
i'm scrutinizing my parenting skills and
where those are lacking or falling short
and
and it just made me you know like kind
of that that good conviction that comes
over me is like hey are you living out
this message with your kids are you
being an example of
inclusion and love and acceptance you
know not just telling them to be that
but also showing it like with my actions
with my life
but then the bad
is when my mind then starts to warp that
and condemn myself for the areas that
i've missed it
so this song is very helpful in just
reminding me
you know
to um see myself the way that god does
and
and uh
be kind to myself the way that i would
be kind to someone else so
um
anyways i hope that however this hits
you i hope that you feel that love and
that approval from god
his acceptance wherever you're at on the
journey
[Music]
i can hear it in your voice that if you
only had a choice
you'd rather be anyone else
i love you just the way that you are
i love the way you made your precious
heart
be kind to yourself
be kind to
know it's yourself to hear it when the
anger in your spirit
is pointing like an arrow to your chest
when the voices in your mind are
anything behind
i love you just the way that you are
i love the way he's shaping
how does
[Music]
learn to love your enemies
be kind you yourself
behind yourself
you gotta learn to love
learn to love your energy
learn to love your enemies
oh thank you worship team um
thank you all for being here tonight
just as a
something else
shame is something that i am very
very familiar with unfortunately
um
something i carry around all the time
everywhere i go every room i'm in every
conversation i've ever been in
something's just always there
um and i again this message probably
hits everybody differently that's the
thing that kind of resonates with me
personally the most it's just my
awareness of my own personal shame that
i carry with me and something that i've
learned not something and something i've
kind of been taught
in a sense thankfully i'm here in this
space
around y'all
and i can shed that
i can shed that here in this church i
can share that here with y'all in this
building i can share that with my faith
and i'm thankful for each one of you
because of it
um so with that being said
if you're one of those people who has
some sense of shame that you're hearing
um
please share that
because we're here for for you for you
all
um
for me personally i'll be in the back if
you need a hug if you need a high five
if you need prayer
um
for anything that you are carrying
because we that's what you are here for
um also if you're a visitor we're glad
that you're here as well there is some
cards in the very back on your way out
that door on a small table um
you can fill that out just your just
some basic information would just like
like know that you're here and just
thank you for being here
and then also if you call the table home
you would like to support this ministry
you can do that online also
there's a
also something in the back as well where
you can make that donation
but some of the things that we also do
at the close of this
service and sometimes i need this
reminder um sometimes i need to hear it
i'm thankful there are people in this
room that i'm like i'm so glad that
so-and-so is here this evening because i
know that they've been struggling with
such and such this week and they need to
hear these words
but then again
i'm glad i'm here this week because i
need to hear these words
[Laughter]
and so with that being said
i'd like to send you out with this
blessing if you wouldn't mind standing
and just as a reminder
of exactly who you are
because you are a child of god
you are a child of god
and that is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go out into your weeks ahead
it is yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace
and unconditional love to everyone you
come in contact with
thank you you guys have a good week
wait wait wait wait wait before anybody
leaves the room i'm so sorry but
we have to acknowledge
karen and gary miner right now
and i know karen is going to be mad at
me later i'm going to hear about this on
our planning call later in the week but
you guys they give
exorbitant amounts of love and energy
and time to this community they've both
had birthdays well karen's tomorrow but
gary's was on thursday and you guys i
just i can't say thank you enough to
both of you i mean i don't know that the
table would have existed past
week two if they were not in the process
and just the the love that y'all pour
out into us is just i mean from the
bottom of our hearts thank you so much
so will you guys join me in singing
happy birthday to you
[Music]
we love you guys thank you thank you now
you may leave